حتى وقت طويل بقي مصباح توماس اديسون
الكهربائي وهاتف جراهام بيل من اهم
الاختراعات البشريه وبقي هذان الاسمان
رمزا في سجلات عظماء التاريخ لكن احدا لم
يذكر الجنديه المجهول الذي اسهم معهما في
تحقيق هذه المنجزات لوس لتمر فما قصته ولد
التي مر عام
1848 في ولايه ماستشيستس الامريكيه كان
والده من العبيد فهرب من الولايه فرجينيا
الى بوستن طلبا للحريه لكن السلطات اعاده
والده لمالكه فتركت والدته لمواجهه الحياه
وحدها مع اربعه اطفال هو اثارهم
اظهر لويس تميزا كبيرا في طفولته ولكنه لم
يتابع دراسته والتحق بالبحريه الامريكيه
وهو في سن السادسه عشر عندما انتهت الحرب
الاهليه عاد الى بوسطن وحصل على وظيفه
مراسل بشركه قانونيه متخصصه في مساعده
المخترعين على حمايه براءات الاختراع
الخاصه بهم
وهناك تعلم الرسم الميكانيكي كما اتقن
الرسم بالمقياس فتحول من مراسل يتقاضى
راتبا قدره ثلاثه دولارات في الاسبوع الى
رسام باجر 20 دولارا
اما الصدفه التي غيرت حياته فكانت لقائه
بالكسندر جراهام بيل الذي استاجره للقيام
برسومات اختراعه الجديد الهاتف فعمل على
المخططات ونجح في جعل بل يحصل على براءه
اختراع الهاتف في الرابعه عشر من فبراير
عام 1876
بعدها نجح التي مر في الحصول على فرصه
كرسام ميكانيكي
ومؤسسي شركه الاضاءه الكهربائيه الامريكيه
ومنح الفرصه للتعرف على مجال الاضاءه
الكهربائيه المتوهجه اثناء ذلك قادته
موهبته لابتكار طريقه لصنع خيوط الكربون
للمصابيح المتوهجه الكهربائيه في عام
كما اشرف على تركيب المصابيح الكهربائيه
في نيويورك وفيلادلفيا ومونتريال وهولندا
وهما فتح امامه افاقا جديده لكنه تحول من
العمل لدى ماكسم الى العمل لصالح منافسه
الذي كان توماس اديسون وكان ذلك في عام
شكلت فرصه العمل مع اديسون اهم حدث في
حياته التي مر حيث شجعه رئيسه الجديد على
تاليف كتاب
اضاءه الكهربائيه المتوهجه وصف عملي لنظام
اديسون الذي يشرح بشكل مبسط كيف ينتج
المصباح المتوهج الضوء كما نجح في ان يكون
احد الاعضاء الثمانيه والعشرين في رواد
اديسون
بعد تركه الوظيفه لدى اديسون عمل التي مر
في شركه استشاريه للبراءات حتى عام
1922 قبل ان يتسبب ضعف بصره وتدهور صحته
بعد وفاه زوجته في انهاء حياته المهنيه في
ايامه الاخيره كان التي ماريه يتبرع بوقته
لتدريس الهندسه الميكانيكيه والرسم
والانجليزيه بينما نشر اولاده كتابا يضم
قصائد شعريه كتبه
وربما ذكر اسم التي مر الذي توفي في عام
1928 على الهامش كجزء من منجزات
الاقتراحات التاريخيه لكنه كان اكثر من
ذلك فهو رسام وموسيقي وشاعر ويكفي ان تذكر
طفولته
ليعرفك رجل مكافح عصامي ايضا